As a choreographer,
I find inspiration in my head.
I am inspired by the space,
the people, the stage.
For me, it’s important to lead workshops
and show that we are independent in our work.
I think it is important
for disabled artists
from other places
to come together.
Firstly, because they can
exchange their experiences,
maybe I should say ‘we’ can exchange
‘our’ experience.
We can learn so much from each other.
Disabled people should lead more workshops,
because I think disabled people's work
is often neglected.
I have the feeling that these people
are excluded from society
and that they can't show their work.
I think non-disabled people
should work with disabled people.
And vice versa. Disabled people should work
with non-disabled people.
This way, they can watch
each other's work
and they can see what is useful for each group
and use it in each project.
I really enjoy doing my job
as a choreographer.
I don't really see myself
as a disabled choreographer.
What really strikes me is that there are
lots of people who want to achieve new things.
They really push themselves
to achieve new things.
And it's really nice to see
what other people do.
Artists with disability
should lead workshops
because in that way they can collaborate
with others and present themselves.
I think that artists with disabilities
should lead workshops
and make performances.
I was dancing with Vivi
and with the teacher.
I showed them my moves,
how to move slowly.
I showed them this way,
from one shoulder to the other,
then we rotated around the back
and came together.
When I dance, everybody understands me.